hello everyone
Karin warden from film courage the radio
show I'm here with the wonderful book
Lois she was kind enough to interview
with us today on our show and Brooke is
a writer director actor producer and she
is found at misny MV dot net Brooke
Lewis comm Philly chick pictures laughs
and the official Brooke Lewis fan page
on Facebook correct
now you have six features six features
that are coming out in 2010 this is
craziness
I know six features coming out to attend
and I'm attached to a bunch of others a
lot of pain and suffering and I'm not
joking no truly um busting my butt pain
and suffering passion commitment focus
sacrifice a lot of sacrifice and I'm
being honest this is not an easy game to
play this business and I'm blessed
there's definitely part luck not
everyone you know gets to do what we do
you know and it's a dream and we're
living the dream literally but it's a
tough challenge to do it it really is
and how do you find time for yourself
among all of this because so much is
demanded of you and you have to be on
and you have to be you know responsible
to your fans
extent where do you find time for
yourself I don't my my me time is
usually going to the gym you know or
when I'll take time to watch a DVR on my
favorite TV shows and I that's about the
most Brooke time I get unfortunately I'm
usually at an event you know that these
days I'm very fortunate to be invited to
a lot of our carpet events and events
that have to do it the business so you
know you want to go and you want to show
your respect and gratitude and so I'm
there a lot and you know yeah I'm
responding a lot to you know autographed
fan mail and stuff like that now so it's
a huge commitment and everyone always
jokes that I'm one of those people now
that's like always on my blackberry
always you know on the email and it's
there's I'm learning I'm still learning
we're all learning every day I'm
transitioning and I'm trying to create
the boundaries of strong boundaries so
that I can balance because I haven't had
a lot of it to be quite honest how do
you recharge your energy you know I love
so much I'm just one of those people
unfortunately I think who just loves
what we do I love acting I really like
producing I love this industry it's just
a part of my heart and soul and so much
of who I am and I hate to identify
myself by what I do because I don't
believe in that but it's such a big part
of I do that that's where like most of
my time and energy goes but recharging
is the little moments when I do spend
time I try to have a love brunch I'm a
big brunch person things I like that
brunch one on one with friends you know
old true friends who you can talk to and
be yourself and really share deep deep
fears and anxieties and stuff like that
you know I love going to the movies I'm
a big go to the movies person to
recharge and turn off the BlackBerry you
know and family and just going back east
to visit family that's my downtime